alors le gentil prace tire à sa grande
épée de son four on est en train dans la
grotte du dragon la grotte était très
sombre
soudain le prince cru entendre léger
bruit bonjour monsieur lisnard dragon
mais non c'est pas dragon c'est moi
casimir que en sétois casimir je vous
écris par moi peur tu divagues j'ai
seulement été quelque peu surpris de ma
passionnés de lecture
c'est un conte de fées sache non bon
casimir que je ne m'abaisserai pas à
lire des histoires aussi stupide que mon
celle d'autres me parle je me
documentais sur des problèmes
mathématiques très important mais c'est
vraiment la première fois j'entends
parler de faits et de dragons dans une
haie pitch de problèmes mathématiques
je ne comprends rien ce que tu veux dire
et puis tu m'énerves à la fin les
soigner tranquillement
bon bon julie christie françois xv
excuses à monsieur du snob est à ce
nombre
tu crois qu est ce qu il fait croire
sains et bien il est en train de lire un
conte de fées et il prétend qu'ils sont
documents sur des problèmes
mathématiques grâce d'abord aux initiés
oui tu t'es peut-être trompé non bonnet
venez avec moi vous allez voir le prince
courageux tu as le quatrième dragons
mais la méchante sorcière en fit
apparaître un cinquième mort horrible
dragon le prince courageux étaient très
épuisé heureusement la bonne fête arrive
a soudain elle va sa baguette
supermagique et ces trials par des
problèmes mathématiques armes dites
vous-même l'a fait
mais je suis qu'à venir et je suis venu
avec pantois et julie très bien j'ai
compris j'étais venu apporter un peu de
qualité par ma seule présence dans ce
jardin mais c'est votre seul but de metz
pionner vous manquez de moi je préfère
me retire alors l'ambition pardonnez moi
mes chers amis mais je ne peux supporter
ce lourdaud je le retire
bon nous sommes très mal conduit il faut
faire quelque chose quasiment va lui
présenter des excuses mais je n'ai fait
que dire la vérité tu n'as fait pour te
moquer de lui un aléa les îles très
gentil bon d'accord mais c'est bien
pourquoi règne à nouveau une ambiance de
paix et de calme dans ce projet elle ne
fait pas l'idiot va vite devant casimir
je vous présente mes excuses à bien mon
pour quasiment tout le monde peut se
tromper mais pourquoi le répéter à tout
le monde mais parce que je n'avais
jamais entendu dire que dans les
problèmes mathématiques il y avait des
histoires de fées et de dragons casimir
non seulement tu es bavard comme une pie
mais tu es bête comme un à un kouao
[ __ ] mais vous vous êtes mes autres
enfants et même pire encore que s'est il
passé le même un double truc à monsieur
du snob m'assure t deux fois pour tenir
et bien il m'a dit que j'étais rats j'ai
oublié sénichault une insulte ça
s'oublie pas il m'a dit que j'étais un
quelque chose comme un truc ta main un
truc et et autre chose comme quelque
chose assez pas précis non il a rien
ajouter d'autres si à chaque fois il y
avait comme un nom d'animal comme un nom
d'animal
tu sais ce qu'on va faire on va demander
aux enfants de nous aider d'accord les
enfants encore oui venez d'où
revoilà kazemi rien demain voilà là tout
le monde est là alors voilà ce qu'on va
faire on va chercher des expressions
habituel dans lesquels il y a un nom
d'animal
moi je vous donne le premier mot et vous
vous me donnez l'animal un exemple et
bien aujourd'hui il fait un froid de
loup alors là tout le monde a répondu
casimir tu répondras de temps en temps
moi je vais essayer où il a retrouvé les
insultes du tué six roms
bon alors on y va on dit malin comme un
patrice a répondu malin comme un singe
vous avez vu les singes aux os oui t'as
vu comme ils ont l'air futé un très
intelligent les renards aussi son malawi
a justement un renard alors on inverse
la commandite ont rusé leur fille comme
un rusé comme un renard est une fable de
la fontaine d'ailleurs le renard et les
réseaux connaissez et le renard et la
cigogne salle commun comme apport salle
comme un cochon vous avez vu les halles
commun les cochons dont l'amour ou là il
se roule mais en réalité ils sont très
gentils ils sont simples ils sont très
gentils féroce commun vous chercher chez
vous un ils reconnaissent comme un lion
non c'est par une assurance comédie
comme un tigre féroce comme un tigre et
vu les tigres dans les documentaires
quand ils y ont bondi sur une compagnie
de gaz est répliquée la manche en trois
minutes en commun ils ont casimir
krakowiak avait un petit peu euros
casimir je t'entends pas beaucoup un mur
at on jamais non parce que moi je suis
muet comme une carpe à bravo kazemi
bravo
alors qu'est ce qu'on disait avant
vaniteux comme un michael a je suis sûr
que lindsay connaissait pas ces grands
oiseaux qui ont dès que magnifique
derrière l'humain pas on dit vaniteux
comme un paon vous avez marché
oui nous sommes très fiers comme ça
voilà avoir la chair de poule vont avoir
la chair de poule
mais parce qu'on est les fumées quand on
a froid ne vous dira avoir froid sur les
bras car sans ça ressemble à une chair
de poule et quand il fait très mauvais
on dit qu'il fait un temps de chien un
temps de chien ont dû aussi un temps de
cochon comme on dit ont dit les deux ans
dit malade comme un chien
et on dit malade comme un chien tu vois
que tu as compris que du maire
alors tu vas trouver toujours un petit
peu plus et on dit aussi bavard comme
une pie la marque commune a vu les pee
wee sais quelle couleur noir et blanc et
on dit aussi autre chose on dit aussi
voleurs comme une pie et voilà et ça
vole ou l'amérique tout ça et brillent
les actifs
si vous laissez une date comme celle du
bas de la fenêtre lac qui arrive elle
apprend dans son bec elle l'enlève
l'oralité une oralité sepa sepa pour la
volée alors casimir est ce que tu as
trouvé ce que je cherchais ne dort
jamais trouvé un lequel un bavard comme
une pie oui et puis on dit aussi d'être
commun et pas bête comme un jeune c'est
bête hanon
on s'est aimés par l'amfar au zimbabwe
on a tenté de simuler comme à mullah
exactement duquel une antique axa de la
5e édition du jeune homme a bien dit
quand j'étais bavard comme une pie et
est bête comme ronald o prouve que
junior et casimir t'en fais pas va parce
que désormais on dira gentil comme un
caillou
[Musique]